an empty chair at the table isn't the
show of unity pacific leaders wanted at
their first in-person meeting in three
years
kiribati decided to leave the group over
a dispute about who should lead the
forum it's been suggested that china was
behind the decision after a period of
increased diplomatic activity in the
region
and it was in that light of geopolitical
rivalry that the us stepped up with an
unprecedented address
at a time when we see bad actors seeking
to undermine the rules-based order
we must stand united
the united states announced a funding
boost for the pacific islands and a plan
to open embassies in kiribati and tonga
the prime minister of tonga says
discussions about the embassy began well
before the recent publicity about china
but if a battle for influence is
underway it could be good for the region
tonga as i'm sure is more specific i'm
very happy that a lot of our
our partners now are paying more
attention to the pacific and and the
issues that we face
australia and new zealand are the
traditional power brokers in the region
the leaders of both have spoken of their
concerns about security deals china has
been signing or trying to sign with some
of the smaller pacific countries
australian prime minister anthony
albinisi and his new zealand counterpart
jacinda ardern are both here in suva
with big delegations a sign that this
pacific islands forum is being taken
more seriously than ever before
presenting the smaller nations with a
prime opportunity to capitalize
a former prime minister of fiji and
former leader of the forum sitavani
rambukha has told al jazeera that
australia and new zealand have taken the
region for granted for too long
they felt that the association and all
the assistance and cooperation
that we've had in the past was enough to
to keep the cohesion of the region
uh
unfortunately uh
everybody's eyes are opening up to
uh what else there is
on the final day of meetings leaders
will release a joint declaration that
will address shared values aspirations
and unity but there's concern among some
here that with increasing geopolitical
competition keeping this group united
will become increasingly difficult wayne
hey al jazeera suva